do TV writers use structure when writing
out episodes and a season okay I think I
answered this earlier when I was talking
about how rooms work and this is really
comes up in the book a lot I have yet
this is happening more and more on drama
drama shows by the way never had rooms
up until not that long ago the drama
room is based on the comedy room and the
comedy room is based on the Sid Caesar
show show of shows from nineteen fifty
six or seven seventy years old whatever
someone didn't like my headline for that
ad I've never forgotten that
he's very valuable with me by the way
but I'm straight up with it you straight
up with it which doesn't make it hurt
any less when you spend and we're back
to Italian hand gestures so so the I'm
sorry could you ask the question oh sure
do TV writers use structure when writing
out episodes and the season episodes
don't work the same way as pilots so
let's say you're on the second year of
Modern Family or the sixth year of
Modern Family the staffs already had
change overs people have left gotten
their own deals their own show first
thing you're gonna get is a Bible and
the Bible show Bible is every show every
episode that's ever been done since the
show started then they're gonna then
you're gonna sit in a room for 12 hours
a day minimum and you're gonna break
store it you're gonna pitch and break
stories then someone then from the from
the break the break is really an outline
then someone is going to go out probably
an assistant and and and type up the
outline from the break and they're gonna
come back in they're gonna they're gonna
go over the outline then somebody is
gonna go out do a pass a draft come back
in the table that rewrite it as a group
so on television episodic TV yes the
showrunners design the arc of the show
and have the say on what's going to
happen but there's a lot of work that
goes on
in the room that has absolutely you know
it's it's lots of things going on at
once but it's a particularly good
question because it's of all they suck
up you be I shouldn't make obscene
gestures I know can you see me if I hit
him in the back of the head but because
it's evolving right now and again it
used to be every character has to remain
the same even though that that episode
is changing so again as Jeffrey said
before you can miss 10 episodes and you
could still follow along with the sitcom
where now it's becoming more episodic
and you kind of have to keep up or all
of a sudden how did we get here all this
has changed so what you're asking is
good only because it's evolving so much
and I'm seeing a shift right but the
part of the question about structure is
I you know there might be chosen doing a
different way but but but I can't see it
not coming out of character in conflict
first so I know for example the most
famous story I don't think it made it
into the book but but but Phil Rosenthal
story about how they got the you know
how did he get the idea for the pilot
which is that he gave his parents in
real life fruit of the Month Club and
his mother had a raging like what what
we're we're too you think we're too old
to go out and get our own fruit you know
and he used that as the part of the
pilot episode that he gave and he gave
that to Doris Roberts and Peter Boyle as
their problem with ray and and so he had
the story idea and you could see
immediate conflict and the great thing
about Raymond was that the stories were
always small with big stakes so that one
another famous episode was somebody in
the room said I I'm having a fight with
my wife because we came back from
vacation and the suitcase is on the line
and all the men in the room said don't
touch it make her go upstairs and all
and the women in the room said the
suitcase for her now that seems like a
really tiny story but it's it's really
about marriage right so they start with
that and then they start because they
know the show they know the characters
they know what they do what they
wouldn't do which you don't know in a
pilot and and so they can say well
raehwan you know deborah would never say
that because basically she loves right
but she thinks he's a dope but also what
Geoffrey's saying goes back to when we
were developing your pilot about this
notion of plausibility and add to it the
notion of identification that people
want to see stuff that feels real to
them that even though I might never have
been put in this situation I know how I
would act if I was in that situation
yeah exactly
I'll tell you what I think is almost an
interesting story um I had a friend who
got stuck on a screenplay and we we sat
down in this very room and I took a
psych history of his character and by
the time he left he said wow it's like
whatever happens to my character now I
know exactly how he'll respond and he
said the rest of the screenplay was just
so easy because he knew his character so
well and I just asked the questions he
filled in all the answers but he'd never
thought about those issues before and
even though you know he's dealing with
how would he react in this business
situation here just understanding which
lunch table he said in in high school
became really important in terms of
developing his character yeah it's kind
of like what I was taught by the guys in
my dad's generation you know even if you
never put it in the script knowing it
helps you and you know 90% in that of
that psychic bio I'm you know that psych
eval probably didn't make it into this
but knowing it makes you more
comfortable and gives you more the more
you know the more you can write it's
that simple
the the other sort of addendum I would
put on this see I used an academic do is
legal term legal Spiegel I would know
the difference between academic oh
that's a Jewish lawyers term so the
other thing I would say about that is
that the great thing for some people
about working in a room is not only do
they know what they're good at they
learn to get good at other things so
there's another position in the room
that people don't talk about much which
is the line editor somebody who's really
good at going line for line and going we
could do a better job on that dialogue
that dialogue is not funny or it's not
and then the joke writer can come up
with so it's really a bolt-in I think
that's the way Hillary as showmen
described it in the book it's when when
we interviewed Leonard Stern he showed
us a book he'd written called a Martian
wouldn't say that yeah my dad's in it
and again it's this idea that you know
these characters so well that when you
hear a line you just say no no she would
never say that but that but when you've
written a book about a Martian you start
knowing the way he would say things that
wouldn't yeah these people in the room
know the characters so well that
everything comes through you feel their
language and and that's the other thing
the corollary to what Peter was saying
earlier corollary another nice word is
yeah it does educating original slogan
it doesn't matter who you know on the in
the room and how close friends you are
if you don't get the show and you
haven't studied it you're not gonna last
that that you know it's not a most show
runners Phil is an exception I think Bob
mired an exception where they will bring
people along but these days there's so
much at stake and there's so many shows
they don't have time to teach people now
my two former students who are on who
are on this new Hispanic version that
Norman Lear is their every day one day
at a time
93 and still mine totally intact that
he's there but she is mentoring these
two
writers and I think it's great you know
she's in her mid-40s and she's mentoring
these two young writers and they're very
fortunate that doesn't always happen and
so they've been when I talked to them
which is frequently they'll say we don't
mind that we're getting less money to
work on Netflix because we're getting in
it's like going to grad school you know
and but it also says something about
your attitude as a writer if you haven't
studied the characters enough so that
you would suggest something that's out
of character so you would say something
is out of character in it and a lot of
people like someone once told me many
years ago that I should write a a
honeymooner spec this is still when they
were looking at specs now they want to
see pilots first and then maybe let you
know four samples that I should write a
Honeymooners as if it was like 2005 I
think it was some pitch that and I said
no I'm not gonna do that because nobody
could write those shows nobody knows the
honeymooners anymore and also it's a
honeymooners dates a little because you
know he was always me you can't say you
know to the moon Alice yeah that to say
just to go back for a second to the to
the business of the I'm blanking on the
word again nor French franchise
franchise is Lucy had a franchise that
people you have to really study the show
to know and that was every week she got
into trouble because she tried to do
something does he didn't wanted to it
was never just going shopping or they
they'd stomp her she and Ethel stomp
grapes or or she went to work because
she wanted so badly to be an actress and
she went to work the veggie valet you
know it's the best one they ever did and
it was always hoisting herself on around
batard trying to get attention but there
always had to be that third object that
makes anything dramatic if it's just
characters in a room talking we're not
gonna follow you but and and and and by
the way conflict and argument are not
the same thing I could start an argument
with your wife right now about her dress
and sorry Peter I stole that from you
that's not conflict and if she argues
but conflict is when something really
important is at stake even if it's a
small thing like I said what suitcase
and anybody can anybody can write an
argument it's like Neil Simon my
favorite Neil Simon quote is he said
everybody thinks they can write a play
you just write down what happened but
the real art is taking from all the
moments of your life of taking disparate
things and bringing them together but
which every said here was really
important ok get that again when he's
off his meds he's like you know when I'm
off my meds
it's dangerous day he needs a little
Adam Levine stroke doesn't help but Sir
the we define I'll go back to what I
said it's really important competition
is defined as having a scarcity of
resources so that's really what
Geoffrey's saying is that the essence of
conflict that you're trying to get
something and somebody else wants it and
you're battling over it so just
disagreeing is not conflict and I would
also quote a wonderful writer who bill
boyars I think was his name he wrote
mostly comedic westerns he wrote those
James Garner movies that were so great
I've forgotten his last name but he
wrote like you know support your local
sheriff support your local gun fire so
he was an action comedic writer and he
said life I'm sure other people have
said it too but he said drama is life
with all the boring parts cut out oh
it's kind of like the John Lennon yeah
you know life is what happens while more
light said the same thing you said Oh
Elmore Leonard said I I don't write the
parts that people don't like to read
right and it really nicely
you
I played hooky from school today this is
a good day for oh you did would you I
don't teach on Tuesday stuff oh okay
perfect according to his students
exactly according to my students I don't
teach any exactly I'm hoping this is a
non evaluative question loving these
terms by the way this is mr. all Peter I
have no clue what he's I don't have any
more clue than you do what telly stuff